props are an integral part of
moviemaking whether they are lightsabers
and Star Wars or Indiana Jones's whips
or Yorick's skull and Hamlet or the
famed book of secrets and national
treasure Book of Secrets
props can become as iconic as a film's
character so Anthony Mason went on a
search he met one prop designer who
makes movie magic with paper and print
Anthony good morning good morning Russ
MacDonald was a printer and illustrator
when a call from filmmaker John Hughes
changed his life used ask MacDonald to
create a book for his film babies day
out MacDonald obliged and ever since
he's gone Hollywood he's a printer by
trade with an impressive collection of
antique type but upstairs in his
Connecticut workshop Ross Macdonald
keeps a different set of tools that's a
bone saw this is actually a bone saw
it's actually a bone saw was it for
sawing the back spine of book blocks
sure you do yeah
MacDonald is a prop maker a master
craftsman who can make a new book look a
century old
he creates many of the signs and
documents you see on screen dangerous to
go to a movie theater with me historical
fun fact when the founding fathers wrote
the Charter their old-timey script made
one of the A's look like a D for the
sitcom parks and recreation he created
the 1817 Pawnee town charter
this is handset wood and metal type
that's actually from that period the
Pawnee charter shall not be changed in
the script only a couple of articles
were spelled out so I actually had to
write copy for the for the rest of the
Charter this is a department of state
seal yes this is the Department of State
this is from madam secretary
every one is someone else's guy
until their your guy he made the
official paperwork for the CBS series
you can get in trouble for these yeah I
know I have had vendors call me and say
exactly how much background research do
you have to do that's probably 75 to 80
percent of the work for four period
props it can be yeah do you enjoy the
search I love it yeah and McDonald is a
stickler for detail so when you see
something on film that's not
historically accurate yeah I die a
little inside it's harder on my family
if they're watching it with me because
I'm like oh no no not Helvetica no
harder still when one of his carefully
crafted props gets little screen time
like the period passport he made for
Boardwalk Empire
this is Nucky Thompson's passport and
these are actual stamps they're printed
and perforated what you did you make
these yourself made the stamps yup but
this was all anyone saw of it passport
on screen you feel a bit like an actor
has been cut out of the film yeah yeah
mcDonald's most famous prop appeared in
national treasure Book of Secrets
he created the fictional book passed
down from George Washington to all
future presidents that holds the
country's darkest secrets were they
specific about wanting all of this no
because they were sort of writing the
the script on the fly for this
they just said create a book of secrets
so I said okay JFK assassination a fake
moon landing skinny SS issue we don't
have time and then I just made up a
bunch of crazy stuff too I made up stuff
about the Titanic this actually sounds
like a lot of fun oh it was so much fun
page 47 just have a look at that I get
letters from kids what's on page 47 what
is on page 47 okay it can finally be
revealed folks nothing sorry to burst
your bubble prop maker secrets another
problem he has in that same movie he had
to make John Wilkes Booth's diary but in
the movie it actually gets pages get
torn out and it gets thrown in the fire
so he had to make a hundred and twenty
copies because the actors sometimes
would tear out the wrong pages or miss
the fireplace there is the scene right
there so that's some of the problems you
have to deal with when you're a prop
maker biggest of course is sometimes you
don't even make it in the fight I can
see why that Boardwalk Empire would be
so hard you spend all that work and then
on camera always that's it and that's
and what is a beauty it's just so
beautiful that's it he obviously has the
craftsmen's joy in the making of this
thing though even if it were to sit in
that he's learned it's all part of this
story and you just got to be ready and
you've got to be ready for your close-up
even if it doesn't come you need to have
like a social media account where we can
see all this kind of so he makes it yeah